all right um let's get started so um
let's see logistical reminder the class
midterm is this Wednesday and it's for
the eighth article midterm and the
logistical details you can find at this
Piazza Post right so the midterm will
start Wednesday evening your $40.00 to
do it and then submit it online through
great scope and because of the midterm
there won't be a section this Friday ok
oh and the midterm will cover everything
up to and including e/m which will spend
most of today talking about Susie they
don't look so stressed it'll be fun all
right
um so what I'd like to do today is start
our foray into unsupervised learning so
far spent a lot of time on supervised
learning algorithms including advice and
how-to applies to advise there any
algorithms in which you'd have you know
positive examples and negative examples
and you run logistic regression or
something or there's V M or something to
find the line find the decision boundary
between them in unsupervised learning
you're given unlabeled data so rather
than given data with x and y you're
given only X and so your training set
now looks like x1 x2 up through XM and
you're asked to find something
interesting about the data
so the first unsupervised learning
algorithm we'll talk about is clustering
in which given a data set like this
hopefully we can have an algorithm that
can figure out that this data set has
two separate clusters and so one of the
most common uses of clustering is market
segmentation if you have a website you
know selling things online we have a
huge database of many different users
and brand clustering to decide what are
the different market segments right so
there may be you know people were
certain age range of a certain gender
are people different age range different
of Education and people
the East Coast versus West Coast versus
also in the country but by clustering
you can group people into different
groups right so I want to show you an
animation of really the most commonly
used the clustering algorithm called
k-means clustering and let me show you
an animation of what k-means does and
then we'll write right out the map and
then how you can implement it so um
let's you're given a set like this so
all these are unlabeled examples so just
exported here and we want an algorithm
to try to find maybe the two clusters
here the first step of k-means is to
pick two points denoted by the two crop
two crosses called cluster centroids and
the cluster centroids are your best
guess for where are the Centers of the
two clusters you're trying to find and
then k-means is an iterative algorithm
and repeatedly you do two things the
first thing is go through each of your
training example oh I'm sorry oh okay
thank you right let me know if it
happens again okay right so right so
right you have two cluster centroids so
the first thing you do is go through
each of your training examples the green
dots and for each of them you color them
either red or blue depending on which is
the closer cluster centroid so here
we've taken every daunting color that
you know red or blue depending on which
side it is which costs essential is
close to two and then the second thing
you do is look at all the blue dots and
compute the average right just find the
mean of all the blue dots and move the
blue cluster centroid there and
similarly look at all the red dots and
look at only the red dots and find it
mean finding oh what's wrong with this
that's it oh this thing was very strange
all right apparently if I keep moving my
mouse it doesn't do that all right thank
you and they find a mean of all the red
dots and move your red cluster centroid
there so let me do that right so the
cluster centroids move as follows to the
mean of the red and the blue dot since
it's just a standard arithmetic gap
and then you repeat again where you look
at each of the dots and color in either
red or blue depending on which cross the
central is closer so when I recolor
every point based on you know what's
closer so that's the new set of colors
and then the second part of the
algorithm was again look at the blue
dots find a mean look at the red cards
find the mean and then move the cluster
centroids over excuse me to that mean
okay
and so and it turns out if you keep
running the algorithm nothing changes so
the arm has converged so if you look at
this picture and you repeatedly color
each point red or blue depending on
which cross the central discloser
nothing changes and if you repeatedly
look at each the two clusters of colored
on same computer mean and move the
cluster there nothing changes so this
album has converged even if you keep on
running these two steps okay so um let's
see let's write down in math what we
just did
all right so this is um a clustering
algorithm and specifically this is a
k-means clustering algorithm so your
data set now does not come with any
labels and so in k-means step one is
initialize the cluster centroids right
I'm gonna call them mu1 up to the UK
random V so this was a step where you
plop down the Red Cross and the Blue
Cross and when I did it on the
powerpoints you know I did it as it will
just choose these as random vectors in
practice is a good way of it they're
actually the most common way to select
their brand-new initial cross the
centroids isn't quite what I showed is
to actually pick K examples out of your
training set and just set the cluster
centroids to be equal to K randomly
chosen the examples right so in the low
dimensional space like a 2d plot you
know they can do on the diagram it
doesn't really matter but when you work
with very hard dimensional data says the
more common way to initialize these two
just pick you know K training examples
and set the cluster centroids to be at
exactly the location of those examples
but then the all dimensional spaces you
know it doesn't make a big difference
and then next you repeat until
convergence one is
right so this is a I just write this
down
so ever since so the two steps you would
alternate between the first one is set
CI for every value of I so for every
example set C are equal to you know
either 1 or 2 depending on whether that
example X is closer to cluster Center 1
no cluster centroid to right so it's as
taking point of color either red or blue
or and we represent that by setting CI
equals 1 or 2 if you have two clusters
if K is equal to 2 oh the note say L 1 R
squared from this morning one else was
sent out this morning oh that's weird
it shouldn't be L 1 norm if it says that
one norm that's a mistake
serve all that but usually and and it
turns out whether you use L 2 norm L 2
norm square they give you the same
answer because the augment is the same
either way but it's usually do a type
one of those oh I see oh god oh oh oh
okay looks like a nose he wrote that
okay cool
but by default when we write that norm
we actually use we mean L 2 norm yeah by
default this is the L 2 norm of X it is
unspecified if it's L 1 norm we usually
write this so L 2 norm is more common
and with what without the square you get
the same image okay thank you
all right so that's colored adults pain
each dot either red or blue and then for
this this is you know some career
examples and take all the examples
assigned to certain cluster right
assigned to cluster J and set new J to
be average of all the points assigned to
that cluster chain yeah oh you know I
don't think I don't know whatever all
right none of the black markers are
working this better
alright let me try to use this is that
part of this is unclear if this part is
you can't see oh I'll write it out more
clearly oh sure I do a place in France
got it
let there be light
all right awesome great that was the
easy request isatis like okay let you
look at it for another minute all right
okay thank you
go for it and this wasn't positive okay
all right now I can move it up
all right um so it turns out that this
algorithm can be proven to converge that
exactly why is written out in the
lecture notes but it turns out if you
write this as a cost function so the
cost function for a certain set of
assignments of points of examples to
cross the centroids and for a certain
set of positions of the cluster
centroids so so see these are the
assignments and these are the centroids
right so so this cost here is some of
your training set what's the squared
distance between each point and the
cluster centroid did this assigned to so
it turns out I won't prove this a little
bit more details legend elsewhere on
truth is it turns out then on every
iteration K means we'll drive this cost
function down and so you know beyond a
certain point this cost function can't
go even you can't go any lower
look just this can't go below zero right
and so this shows that k-means must
converge release this function must
converge because there's a strictly
non-negative function that's going down
on every derivation so at some point
that has to stop going down and then you
could declare gave me a self converged
in practice if you're running k-means
and i'm very very large dataset then as
you plot the number of iterations j may
go down and you know and and just
because of lack of compute or lack of
patience you might just stop this
running after a while it is going down
too slowly
so that's sort of k-means in practice
but maybe hasn't totally conversions
just cut it off and call it good enough
now the most frequently asked question I
get the k-means is how do you choose K
it turns out that I when I use k-means i
still usually choose K by hand and so
and
why which is in a supervised learning
sometimes it's just ambiguous right how
many clusters there are what this data
said some of you will see two clusters
and some of you will see full clusters
and it's just inherently ambiguous what
is the right number of clusters so there
are some formulas you can find online
with criteria like AIC and B I sieve
automatically choosing the number of
clusters in practice I tend not to use
them
because I usually look at the downstream
application of what you actually want to
use k-means for in order to make a
decision on a number of classes so for
example if you're doing a market
segmentation here because you're
marketers want to design different
marketing campaigns right for different
groups of users then your marketers
might have the bandwidth to design for
separate marketing campaigns but now the
hundred marketing campaigns so they'll
be good reason to choose for clusters
rather than hundred clusters so as often
if you look at the purpose of what
you're doing this for I think in the
program exercise in homework do you see
a image compression exercise where you
want to cluster colors into smaller
number of clusters do you implement this
it's actually one of the most fun
exercises I think but but so there you
you know be saying well how much do you
want to compress the image to decide how
many clusters to try to use okay so I
usually pick the number of clusters you
know either manually or looking at what
you want to use Kanis cluster for are
you trying to cluster news articles like
the Google News example I think I showed
in the first nature you say well how
many clusters kind of make sense for
news articles okay all right so
oh sure welcome to yet second local
minima oh yes
kami intercepts of the local minima
sometimes and so if you're worried about
local minima or the thing you can do is
run k-means say ten times or 100 times
1,000 times from different random
initializations of the cluster centroids
and then run it you know say a hundred
times and then pick whichever run
resulted in the lowest value for this
cost function alright so you play up
this more in in the program exercise
know there's a there's a problem that
seems so closely related but but there's
actually quite different where he's
arrived the algorithms which is density
estimation so let me motivate this I
actually about well right some time back
has some friends working on a problem
which I simplified little bits of you
know if you have aircraft engines coming
off the assembly line alright and every
time an aircraft engine comes on the
assembly line you measure some features
of this engine so you measure some
features about the vibration and you
measure some features of all the heat
that the aircraft engine is producing
and let's say that you gathered a set
and the anomaly detection problem is if
you get a new aircraft engine that comes
off the assembly line and if the
vibration feature it takes on this value
and the heat feature takes on this value
is that aircraft engine an anomalous one
this is your
right and so the application of this is
that as your aircraft engine comes off
the assembly line if you see a very
unusual signature in terms of the
vibrations and heat the aircraft engine
is generating then probably something's
wrong with this aircraft engine if your
people have you have your team inspected
further or tested further before you
should the airplane before you ship the
engine tort or airplane may occur and
then something goes around the air and
there's a there's a major accident a
major disaster right
and so anomaly detection is most
commonly done or one of the common ways
to implement anomaly detection is the
model P of X which is given all of these
blue examples given all these thoughts
can you model what is the density from
which X was drawn so then if P of X is
very small then you flag an anomaly
meaning that gee I think something's
funny here and maybe someone should
inspect this aircraft engine a little
bit further sonar detection is used for
tasks like this for inspection tossed
like this is used for many years ago as
su work of some telecoms providers with
you know helping out telecoms company e
on anomaly detection to figure out if
something's gone wrong with part of this
cells her network right so if one day
one of the South Tower starts throwing
off network patterns that seem very
unusual then maybe something's wrong
with that cell tower like that
something's gone wrong it sent out the
technician to fix it it's also used a
computer security of a computer save
computer Stanford start sending are very
strange
you know network traffic there's very
unusual relative their views on the four
browser what was this is a very
anomalous network traffic then maybe IT
stops you have a look to see if that
good computer has been hacked so these
are some of the applications that were
an all new section and what good way to
do this is given the unlabeled data set
model P of X and then if you have very
low probability examples you flag that
as a possible anomaly for further study
now given this data sets how do you
model this one distinct thing about this
green dots is that neither the vibration
no the heat signature is actually out of
range right you know like there are a
lot of aircraft engines with vibrations
in that range they're long of aircraft
engines with heat in that range so
neither feature by itself is actually
data unusual it's actually the
combination of the two that is unusual
and so that's less what I want to do is
uh come up with an algorithm to model
this and in fact welcome of an algorithm
they can model you know maybe maybe your
data density looks like this made more
of an L shape like that but how do you
model P of X with the data coming from
an L shape and it turns out that there
is no textbook distribution right you
know there isn't you know if you look at
this simple and there's no exponential
family model the types of distributions
there is no distribution for modeling
very very complex distributions like
this so what I'm going to talk about is
the mixture of gaussians volatile which
would look for data like this and say it
looks like this data actually comes from
two Gaussian there's one Gaussian maybe
that's one type of aircraft engine that
you know it's drawn from a Gaussian like
the one below and a separate aircraft
type of aircraft engine that's drawn
from a Gaussian like that above and this
is why there's a lot of probably Mars in
just O'Shea region by very low
probability outside that O'Shay region
right oh and these ellipses I'm drawing
other contours of these two gaussians
right and so what I'd like to do next is
develop the mixture of gaussians model
which is useful for an audience section
and and and then those this will lead us
to our second unsupervised so in order
to make the mixture of gaussians model a
bit easier to develop let me just use a
one-dimensional example where so let's
see so let's say that we gather data set
that looks like
this so it's just one roll number
searches online I've plotted a few dots
um so looks like this day there maybe
comes from two gaussians or it looks
like you know there's some data from
this Gaussian and there's some data from
that Gaussian on the right um and it's
and if only we knew right which example
had come from which Gaussian if if we
knew that these examples that come from
Gaussian one we wanted to know with
crosses and if only we knew what the
actually this finally fell over if only
we knew that these examples that come
from Gaussian to which I'm willing to
draw with oles then we just fake calcium
1/2 the crosses figure out into the O's
and then we'd be pretty much done right
oh and sorry and so these are the two
gaussians and so the overall density
would be something like this right
that's the probability of all the party
muscle left while probably must know
very low less probably mass on so the
overall density just told again would be
no high no high something like that
right but the reason and then if you
actually had these labels if you knew
that these examples came from gaussian
one those examples come from gaussian
two then you can actually use an
algorithm very similar to GD a gaussian
difference to fit this model the problem
with this density estimation problem is
you just see this data and maybe the
data came from two different gaussians
but you don't know which example
actually came from which coliseum okay
so the e/m algorithm or the expectation
maximization algorithm will allow us to
fit a model
despite not knowing which Gaussian each
example
so let me first write down the young
mixture of gaussians model and then
we'll describe the EML room for this so
let's imagine let's suppose that there's
a so the term we sometimes use this
latent but latent just means hidden
observed
so so let's imagine that there's some
hidden random variable Z and the term
latent just means hidden on observe it
means that it exists but you don't get
to see the value directly so I say later
it just means hidden on observe so let's
imagine that this hidden or latent
random variable Z and Xin Z I had this
joint distribution and this this this is
very very similar to the model you saw
in Gaussian destroyers but Zi is
multinomial with some set of parameters
Phi for a mixture of two gaussians this
would just be Bernoulli with two values
but if you're a mixture of K calcium's
then Z you know can take on values from
1 through K and it was two gaussians it
just before nearly and then once you
know that one example comes from
Gaussian number J then X condition that
Zi is equal to J that is drawn from a
Gaussian distribution with some mean and
some coherence Sigma okay so the two
unimportant ways this is different than
GTA one well I set Z to be one of K
values instead of one of two values and
GDA god-centered from analysis we had Z
know why the labels Y took on one of two
values and then second is I have Sigma J
instead of Sigma so by convention when
we feed mixture of gaussians models we
let each gaussian have his own
covariance matrix Sigma we could
actually force it to be the same way you
want but these are the trivial
differences the most significant
difference is that in Gaussian districts
I Y I whereas Y was observed and the
main difference between this and
Gaussian disappearing analysis is now we
have replaced that with this latent or
hidden random variables Z are they
do not get to see in the training set
okay so all right that was better
all right so if we knew the sea-ice
right then we can use maximum likelihood
estimation right so if only we knew the
value of the Z is which we don't but if
only we did then we could use maximum
likelihood estimation or mo e to
estimate everything you know so we were
right the log likelihood other
parameters equals some log P of X our Zi
you know given the parameters right and
then you take the river to set the ders
equal to zero and you guys did this in
problem set one right and then you find
that Phi J is equal to 1 over m
okay so if only you knew the values of
the sea-ice then you could use maximum
likelihood estimates and this is what
you get and this is pretty much the
formulas actually these two are exactly
the formulas we had for Gaussian Tuscon
analysis except we'll replace Y with Z
and then there's some other formula for
Sigma just written in the lecture notes
but I won't that one right down here
okay um
but the reason we can't use this use
these formulas we don't actually know
whether the values of Z so what we will
do in the e/m algorithm is two steps in
the first step we will guess the value
of the Z's and in the second step we
will use these equations using the
values of disease we just guessed so let
me so sometimes in machine learning
something to call this a bootstrap
procedure where you get something they
run an algorithm you're using your
guesses and then you update your guesses
and then run the algorithm okay let me
let me make that concrete by writing
this down
so the e/m algorithm has two steps the a
step also called the expectation step is
set w IJ so W IJ is going to be the
probability that Zi is equal to J okay
given all the parameters and and much as
we did with generative learning
algorithms right with generative
learning algorithms we'll use Bayes rule
to estimate the probability of Y given X
and so to compute this you use a similar
Bayes rule type of calculation and so
disappear
right where for example this term here P
of X i given Z I equals J this would be
a Gaussian density right this comes from
a Gaussian density with mean mu J and
covariance Sigma J right and so this
term here would be a 1 over you know 2
pi it's an N over 2 Sigma J and then
this term here I guess this would be a
Phi J that's just a Bernoulli
probability remember Z is multinomial
right Suzy this multinomial we're
parameters Phi so I guess the parameters
v for multinomial distribution tell you
what's the chance of Z B 1 2 3 4 and so
on up to K so the chance of Zi being for
the K is just this chance of Zi pee
really Jane is just Phi J right it's
just read it off one of the parameters
and your multinomial probability but for
the also CV different values okay and so
and similarly the terms of denominator
this term here is from Gaussian and that
second term is from the multinomial
probability that you have for Z and so
that's how you plug in all of these
numbers and use Bayes rule use this
equation to compute given all given the
position of all these gaussians what is
the chance of W IJ taking on a certain
value
and and and so to to make this really
concrete you remember how I guess ones
and zeros are the other way if you were
to look at these if you were to scan
through right to left
remember how you know you give the
sigmoid function right the same point
can be this way or this way or interval
sign I guess these are positive examples
these negatives you have a sigmoid
function like this and so W IJ is just
the height of this Sigma is just a
chance you know each of these examples
being coming from either the Z equals 1
is equal 0 and then you store all of
these numbers in the variables W IJ okay
so W IJ is just compute the posterior
chance of discharge this example coming
from the nest Gaussian present right now
saying they just saw that W IJ so that's
the e set and you compute the W IJ for
every single training example I mix the
m-step is
sorry is this what oh this one you're
sorry okay so in the so the e step tells
us you know trying to guess the values
of the Z's right we figure out what's
the probability of Z being one two three
four after Cain was stolen here and then
in the m-step what we're going to do is
use the formulas behalf for maximum
likelihood estimation and I want you to
compare these with the equations I had
above okay see but so these equations
are a lot like the equations above
except that instead of indicator Z I
equals J we replaced it with W IJ right
which by the way is the expected value
of this indicates a function because the
expected value of an indicator function
is just equal to the probability of that
thing in the middle being true and then
there's a formula for Sigma J as well
that's all you can get from the lecture
notes but I want I won't write down here
okay so one intuition of this mixture of
gaussians algorithm is that it's a
little bit like k-means but with Sophos
i'm in so in k-means in the first step
we will take each point and just assign
it to one of the clade k cluster
centroids right and it was a little bit
closer to the red cluster centroid than
the blue cluster centroid we would just
assign it to the red cross
so even with just a little bit closer
one closer than another k-means we just
make what's called a hard assignment
meaning you know whatever plus the
centroid is closed assume we just
assigned at a hundred percent to that
say cluster centroid so yeah is you can
think well yeah implements a softer way
of assigning points to to the different
cluster centroids because instead of
just picking the one closest Gaussian
Center and the signing of there it uses
these probabilities and gives it a
weighting in terms of how much the sign
to calcium want versus gals into and
then second obtains you know the means
accordingly write sum over all the
excise to the extent you're assigned to
that cluster centroid divided by the
number of examples assigned to a cluster
centroid okay so so so that's one
intuition behind between them and
k-means and in a second but but when you
run this algorithm it turns out that
this algorithm will converge with some
caveats I'll get to later and this will
find a pretty decent estimate of the
parameters you know say fitting a
mixture of two gaussians model so this
is some they owe and so if you are given
the data set of say airplane engines you
can run this algorithm for the mixture
of two gaussians and then when a new
airplane engine rolls off the assembly
line you so after your fitting the
k-means algorithm you now have a after
15 ml room you now have a joint density
of a p of x comma Z and so the density
for X is just sum over all the values of
Z P of X comma Z and so
and so a mixture of gaussians can fit
distributions that look like this it can
fit distributions that look like this
right there's these up these are both
mixtures of two Gaussian so this gives
you a very rich family of models to fits
very complicated distributions and now
that right and you've also fit no know
something like this so this is a mixture
of two gaussians I guess one thin narrow
Gaussian here and one much wider fatter
Gaussian so mixture of two gaussians
can't you fill them all the different
things can fit a lot and the mixture of
more than two gaussians can fit even
richer models and so by doing this you
can now model P of X for many
complicated densities including this one
this example I just now this will allow
you to fit a priori density function
that puts some all the promos on on a
region that looks like this
and so we have a new example you can
evaluate P of X and a P of X is large
then you can say you know this looks
okay and the P of X is less than Epsilon
you can find in an RV and say Oh take a
look take another look at this airplane
engine okay
so um I kind of just wrote down this
algorithm with a little bit of a hand
wavy explanation at the house derive
right so I said if only you knew the
values of C and just used maximum
likelihood estimation
so let's guess the values of Z and then
plug that into the formula so maximum IQ
estimation it turns out that hand-wavy
explanation works in the particular case
of
Yampa mixtures of gaussians but that
there is a more formal way of deriving
the EML rhythm that shows that this is a
maximum likelihood estimation algorithm
and then it converges at least the local
optimum and in particular there what
we'll do is show that if you go is given
a model P of X Z prior tries by theta if
you go this to maximize P of X right
excuse me
right so this is what maximum likely
you're supposed to do that
eeehm is exactly trying to do that okay
so I'll go on in a minute present this
more general derivation that the full
morris derivation of the e/m algorithm
that doesn't rely on this hand wavy
argument of thus guesses ease and use
master like you were to guess value so
I'll do the rigorous derivation of VM in
a minute but before I do that let me
just pause and check if there are any
questions maybe let's see maybe I'll
help to not think of them as weights
yeah I think this is actually there
waiting you assigned to a certain
Gaussian so that's one intuition and
hence weights but so one way to think of
this as W IJ is how much X I is assigned
to you know to do so W IJ is a strength
of how strongly you want to assign that
training example X I to that cluster or
to that to that particular Gaussian and
so this is a number of G 0 and 1 right
and the strength of all the assignments
and every point is a sign with a total
strength equal to 1 because all these
properties must sum up to 1 and so when
I take this point and assign it you know
0.82 more close gaussian and point to to
a more distinct
and this is our guest though you know
well there's an 80% chance of him but
that gal seen a 20% chance of camera a
second girl seen this make sense oh I
see so let's see um so when you're
running the ml room you never know
whether the true values of Z all right
you're given the data set so you only
told the excess and false we know these
airplane engines were generated off you
know two different gaussians maybe there
are two separate assembly processes you
know one from the one from plot number
one one from plot number two and maybe
they're actually operate a little bit
differently but by the time they merge
onto one but by the time the two
supplies of aircraft engines get to you
they've been mixed together and so you
can't tell anymore which aircraft engine
came from profit pond one and which
profit aircraft engine came from plant -
I don't even know there are two fonts
you just see the stream of aircraft
engines you're hypothesizing they're the
two types and so in every iteration of
PM you're taking each aircraft engine
and guessing you know for this one I
think does 80% chance that came for
process one the 30% chance came for
process - so that's the e step and then
in the m-step you look at all the
engines that you're kind of guessing
were generated by process one and you
update your Gaussian to be a better
model for all of the things that were
that you kind of think were generated by
process one and if there's something
that you're absolutely sure came from
process one then it has a weight of one
close to one and this do you think there
was something that you know are the 10%
chance come to process 1 then that
example is given a lower weight and how
you update the meaning for that
all right so
well I still remember when I was an
undergrad doing a summer internship at
AT&T Bell Labs and then someone the few
offices down had learned about diem for
the mixture of gaussians her first time
was running on his computer and he's
going around to every single office
saying oh my god you gotta check this
out this is unbelievable look at what
this elephant can do Tiffany makes is a
Gaussian so it shows you those other
people I hang out with all right um so
in order to derive you know so slightly
hand wavy arguments that oh let's get to
let's guess the values of the Z's let's
just have these ways and plug them into
maximum likelihood um what I like to do
is give a more rigorous derivation for
ye M algorithm is a reasonable algorithm
and Y is a massive likely estimation
algorithm and why we can expect it to
converge and it turns out there rather
than just proving you know that this is
a sound algorithm what we'll see on
Wednesday is that this view of p.m.
allows us to derive em in a in a more
correct way for other models as well
they make sense of gaussians on
Wednesday we'll talk about a model
called factor analysis unless you model
gaussians an extremely high dimensional
spaces where if you have a thousand
dimensional data but only thirty
examples how do you for the girls into
that so we talked about that on
Wednesday and it turns out this
derivation that yeah we're gonna go
about through now is crucial for
applying M accurately in problems like
that so in order to lead up to that
derivation let me describe Jensen's
inequality so let F be a convex function
to do yeah we're actually going to need
concave functions so be all - of
everything but what gets it done in a
second but so a convex function means
the second derivative is greater than 0
or in other words it looks like that
right so that's a convex function that X
be a random variable then F of the
expected value of x is less than equal
to the expected value of x
maybe young here's an example right so
here's a let's see that's the function f
of X and let's say that these are the
values 1 2 3 4 5 and suppose that X is
equal to 1 with probability 1/2 is equal
to 5 probably just an illustration then
here is the F of 1 here is F of 5 here
is f of 3 and F of 3 is f of the
expected value of x right because so the
expected value of x and sometimes I
write 2 so called the square brackets
it's the average of X is equal to 3 and
so the expected value seems to be F of
the expected value of x is equal to this
value whereas the expected value of f of
X is the mean of F of 1 and F of 5 right
so the expected value of f of X f of X
is a 50% chance of being F of 1 and a
50% chance of being a 4/5 and so the
expected value of f of X is equal to
this value in the middle let's really
take these two take this value and this
value and take the mean so it's this
value up here and and this value
expensive value and so in this example
the expected value of f of X is greater
than F of the expected value of x as
predicted by Jensen's inequality I'm
going to just draw one illustration that
may or may not help is some of my
friends like it I sometimes use it but
it was confusing then don't worry about
it but it turns out that if you draw a
line that connects these two then the
midpoint of this line is the height of F
of expected value of x right so the
height of this you know so given these
two points this point in this point if
you draw this line it's called a chord
then the height of this point is
expected value of f of X and this point
is f of the expected value events and in
any convex function you know really take
any convex function that's also called
back function if you draw any chords
that mean point it's always higher right
then that group Green Point which is Y
which is another way of seeing Y
Jensen's equality holds true okay if
this visualization doesn't help don't
worry about it but it's just so actually
what a lot my friends do is we the cell
you know we keep on forgetting which
direction Jensen's equality goes that's
not great that Sol all of my friends
were don't remember we draw this picture
and draw that chord and if we quickly
figure out which we do equality girls
all right so one addendum further it's
strictly greater than zero
and so if this is the case we say F is
strictly convex so let's see a straight
line is also convex function right so
this is the convex function this
congressional district on various ocean
turns out a straight line that's also a
convex function but so in this addendum
is saying that if F is a strictly convex
function meaning racing it's not a
straight line right bit more than is not
a straight line but if the curvature if
it's always bending up then the only way
for the left and right hand sides to be
equal is an X is a constant meaning it's
a random variable that always takes on
the same value
okay so Jensen's equality says that you
know left hand sides got to be the same
as right hand side sorry I think I
reversed the order of these two for that
equation that doesn't matter right so
Jennison equality says left hand side is
always less than equals to the right
hand side and the only way is equal is
if X you know is a random variable that
always takes on the same value
yeah
so it turns out what if the other have
one single that now the another feat it
turns out does vary so let's see so one
way that could happen would be if the
function were like that and then if you
take the drawing horde we take the
meanest no higher then this Impala if
you had a flat part here then the
function is not strictly convex and so
it's still less than equal to but it's
not but it can't be equal to Y of X is
random so um and and and we'll use this
in a little bit well actually end up
using this and again for the strict
proper low states you know if those of
you that don't know take classes in
advanced probability the technical way
of saying X is a constant is X's equal
to DX
we're probability one you know what I
think for all practical human purposes
you do not need to worry about this but
if you think the cost in measure theory
the professor in measure theory will be
happy if you say this then you say X is
a constant but maybe maybe none of you
know okay this is don't worry about it
oh yes okay now um just one one more
addendum to this is that the form of
Jensen's equality we're gonna use is
actually a form for a concave function
so instead of convex I'm gonna say
concave and so you know a concave
function is just a negative of a convex
function right if you take a convex
function and take negative of that it
becomes concave and so the whole thing
works with the with everything flipped
around the other way
okay so the phone with Jensen's
inequality we're going to use it's
actually the concave foam with Jensen's
equality and we're actually going to
apply it to the log function so the log
function write log X looks like this and
so that's a concave function and so the
inequality will use to be in this
direction to have an orange
all right
so just the density estimation problem
meaning density estimation means you
want to estimate P of X all right so we
have a model of a P of X comma Z with
parameters theta and so you know instead
of writing out Mu Sigma Nu Sigma Phi
like we did for the mixture of gaussians
I'm just gonna capture all the
parameters you have whatever your
parameters are obviously capture them in
one variable theta and you only observe
thanks so your training set looks like
that so the UM log likelihood of the
parameters theta is equal to some of
your training examples log hearings i
franchised by theta and this in turn is
log of sum over Z P of X I see I
franchise by theta right because P of X
you know is just taking the Joint
Distribution and summary notes
marginalizing out Zi
and so what we want is maximum
likelihood estimation which is to find
the value of theta that maximizes is
long likelihood and what well like what
we'd like to do is derive in year now
derive an algorithm which will turn out
to be an e/m algorithm as an iterative
algorithm for finding the mass of life
for an estimate of the parameters theta
so let me draw a picture that I could
keep in mind as we go through the math
which is you know the horizontal axis is
a space of possible values of parameters
theta and so there's some function o of
theta then you try to maximize
and so what yen does is lesson you
initialize theta at some value may be
randomly initialize so similar to the
k-means clustering we just you know
randomly initialize your muse for that
ratio gaussians what the IAM algorithm
does is in the east step we're going to
construct a lower bound shown in green
here for the log likelihood and this
lower bound is being curve has two
properties one is it is a lower bound so
everywhere you look you know over all
values of theta the green curve lies
below the blue curve so this is a lower
bound and the second property that the
green curve has is that it is equal to
the blue curve at the current value of
theta so what the east step does which
you will see later on and just keep this
picture in mind as we go through the
east of an e/m set is um it'll construct
the lower bound it looks like this right
oh and and also to foreshadow a part of
the derivation right there was that
addendum to Jensen's equality what we
said well under these conditions it
holds with equality right here if f of X
equals F of G of X we said well the two
things are equal with under certain
conditions we want things to be equal we
want the green curve to be equal to the
blue curve at the old value of theta so
what we'll use that addendum to just
inequality when we do like that so
that's estep is draw the green curve and
then what the m-step does is it takes a
green curve and it finds the maximum
so what the em set does is it takes a
green curve and it finds the maximum and
one step of eeehm will then move theta
from this green value to this red value
okay so the e step constructs the green
curve and the m-step finds the maximum
of the green curve and this is one
iteration of M the second iteration of M
now that you're at this red thing is
will construct a new lower bound again
you know is it different though about
everywhere the red curve is below the
blue curve and the values are equal at
this new value that's the e step and an
M step will maximize this red curve and
so on now you're here construct another
thing do that and you can kind of tell
that they keep running eeehm this is
constantly trying to increase L of theta
trying to increase the log likelihood
until it converges to local optima they
give Albert does converge only to local
Optima so if you if there was another
even bigger thing there that they may
never find its way over to that other
better optimum but the e/m algorithm by
repeatedly doing this will hopefully
converse to a pretty good local optimum
all right so that's right to how we do
that
so I've already said that our goal is to
find the Frances data then maximize this
and so that equation we said or just now
is some of our I log some of the Zi P X
Y comma Z i given theta okay so this is
just what we had written down I guess on
the left what I'm going to do next is
divided by I must find if I buy this
where a Qi of Zi is a probability
distribution
ie some of us Zi Qi of Zi equals one so
with the multiplying defined by some
high resolution and we'll decide later
how to come up with this probably this
usually Qi right but you know I'm
allowed to construct a prize
distribution and multiply and divide by
the same thing right
now if you look at this all right let's
put square brackets here
if these Qi is this a probably
distribution meaning that some of us Zi
Qi Zi sums over from some some one then
this thing inside is equal to sum of I
of an expected value of Zi drawing from
the Qi distribution we use colors to
make this clearer
right so the way you compute the
expected value of you know some function
of Z is you sum over all the possible
values of Z I of the property of Zi
times what if that function is so this
equation is just the expected value who
respect to Z I drawn from that Qi
distribution of that thing in the square
brackets in the purple square brackets
now using the concave form of Jensen's
inequality we have that this is greater
than or equal to so this is a form of
Jensen's equality where f of X is
greater than or equal to X where here
this is the logarithmic function so the
log function is a concave function it
looks like that and so using the I guess
you use it using the form of Jensen's
equality with the science reverse write
f of e^x is great enclose in a of FX so
you get log of expectation is pretty
equal to expectation it along
and then finally let me just take this
expectation and unpack it one more time
so this is now sum of I sum of Zi so I
just took this expected value and turn
the back to the sum over random variable
probably times that thing okay so if you
remember this picture from the middle
what we wanted to do was to construct a
function construct this green curve
there's a lower bound for the blue curve
and if you view this formula here as a
function of theta right so your X X is
just your data and Z is a variable you
sum over so this whole thing is the
function of theta or because X is FX Z
is yourself you found some over so this
whole formula here this is a function of
the parameters theta and what we're
showing is that this thing you know this
formula here this is a lower bound for
the log likelihood I thought for this
thing I guess this is our theta so
oh how we got to disagree sure sure so
messy let's go let's say that Z takes on
values from 135 right unless these
details on Val's room one through ten
zero attend sided guys and I want to
compute you know the expected value of
some function of some function G G of Z
right then expected value G of Z is sum
of all the possible values of C of the
probability do you get that Z times G of
Z right so that's that's what's the
expected value of a function of a random
variable right and and this is the
expected value of Z is some of us Z P of
Z times Z right that's the average of
random variable and so in the notation
that we have the probability of Z taking
on different values is to note about a
of Z which is why we wind up with that
formula does make sense okay
all right if one of these steps doesn't
make sense then you know other questions
okay
all right
now one of the things we want when
constructing this green lower bound is
we want that green lower bound to be
equal to the blue function at this point
right this is actually how you guarantee
that when you optimize the green
function by improving on the green
function you're improving on the blue
function so we want this lower bound to
be tight right to meet the two functions
being equal or tangent to each other so
in other words we want this inequality
to hold with equality so we want yeah so
we want the left-hand side on the
right-hand side to be equal for the
current value of theta
so on a given iteration with the current
perhapses equal to theta we want we want
I know this is a lot of math but you
know we wanted the left and right hand
sides to be equal to each other because
that's what it means for almost for the
lower bound to be tight for the green
curve to be exactly touching the blue
curve as we construct that know about
and so for this to be true we need the
random variable inside to be a constant
so we need p of x i zi / qi of zi to be
equal to constitutes a constant meaning
that no matter what value of Zi you plug
in this should evaluate to the same
value you know in other words the ratio
between the numerator and denominator
must be the same and fortunately so far
but not yet specified how will choose
this distribution for zi right so so far
the only constraint we have is that Qi
has to be a probability density has
their probability distribution over Zi
we could choose whatever distribution
you want for Zi and it turns out that
we can set qi of zi to be proportional
to p of x i zi parametrized by theta and
this means that for any value of Z you
know whether those e indicates is it
from Gaussian one of Gaussian to right
so this means that the chance of
Gaussian one is proportional to the
chance of Gaussian one versus goes into
whether Zi takes on one or two is
proportional to this and I don't want to
prove it but one way to ensure this and
this is proven in the lecture notes but
it turns out that one way to ensure well
so the Q is need to sum to one so one
way to ensure that this is proportional
to the right hand side is to just take
the right hand side so one so let's see
right so the cure eyes have to sum to
one and so one way to ensure the
proportionality is to just take the
right hand side and normalize it it's
something one and after after a couple
steps that intellectually I don't want
to do here you can show that this
results in 7qi of zi to be equal to that
that posterior probability okay and so
sorry I skipped a couple of steps here
you can get from the lecture notes but
it turns out that if you want this to be
constant meaning whether you plugged in
CI equals 1 or Z equals 2 or whatever
disavows the same constant the only way
to do that is make sure the numerator
and denominator are proportional to each
other and because qi of zi is a density
that must sound
one one way to mr. Li proportional it
was to just said this to be really right
hand side but normalize the sum to one
okay and then we derived this a little
bit more carefully your lecture notes so
just to summarize this gives us de em
algorithm let's take all this everything
we're just doing Rapids Indian algorithm
and it Estep we're going to set Q I of
Zi equal to that and previously this was
the W IJ s right so incentive so
previously restoring these probabilities
and the variables you call WI J's and
then in the M step we're going to take
that know about that we constructed
which is this function and maximize it
with respect to theta okay and so
remember in the M set we constructed
this thing on the right hand side
there's a lower bound for the log
likelihood and so for the fixed value of
Q you can maximize this respect to theta
and that updates the theta
you know maximizing the green lower
boundary that's what the end step does
and if you any rate these two steps then
you find that this should converge to
the whole optimal okay oh and there's
just maybe that's the obvious question
um why don't we try to maximize vary
theta why we try to massage the log like
indirectly it turns out that if you take
the mixture of gaussians model try to
take derivatives of this and set their 2
is equal to 0
there's no known way to solve for the
value of theta the maximizing the log
likelihood but you'll find that for the
mixture of gaussians model and for many
models including factor analysis we
talked about on Wednesday if you
actually plug in the Gaussian density if
you actually plug in the mixture of
gaussians model for p and take you know
take take the riveter cetera t goes here
and solve you will be able to find an
analytic solution to maximize this M
step and it'll be exactly what we have
worked out ok but so this derivation
shows that the yam algorithm you know is
a maximum likelihood estimation
algorithm with optimization solved by
constructing little balance and
optimizing those bounds ok all right
that's it for today and only it's tough
up to here right and so this stuff will
be up to midterm but we're talking about
on factor analysis we're not on my way
okay
so let's break for today and I'll see
you guys on Wednesday